Chad do you find that most Hollywood
actors are competitive or actresses yeah
I think this is a very competitive town
and I think we do have a lot of
competition out there but again I always
say this again to other actors that ask
me I say the competition is really with
yourself that's it you're competing with
you at the end of day it's you yes
you're gonna have actors that you come
against and maybe you're gonna lose that
role
well that role was not meant to be yours
I think a role is so personal that it
goes to the person that it's meant to go
to you know do I think anybody else
could play - I'm supernatural no you
know what I mean am i right for this
movie that Edward Norton got no that's
him it's it's it's a very personal thing
a role so I I think that the the
competition is with you you need to be
able to step up and do it and believe
that you're gonna be the one that's
going to get the job and it might not go
your way and it just wasn't meant to be
and that's how I deal with it it's like
all right it's not meant to be so it's
it's not my role but you have to go
through all those auditions in order to
get that one part and you may know I
mean I know most of the time I'm
probably not gonna get this this is not
the guy they're looking for but you go
in and you have to take that step in
order to get to the job that you're
gonna get maybe five six maybe ten
twenty auditions down the road you have
to do it was this always your mindset or
did it evolve over time yeah I think it
evolved over time
I've been lucky in that my career has
gone very step by step by step by step
by step frustrating at times because I
just want to be like yeah you go here
and and life will be great I don't think
it works that way
I've had friends go from here to here
really really fast and that must you
know with with their brain I think I
I yeah I've been very lucky and that
I've had a slow burn in this business
and and I've worked a lot and have done
things that have been very recognizable
so I feel blessed that I've sort of been
kept in check along the way and taken
those proper steps and been able to have
a healthy perspective about it
22 years later back when I was younger
it was just like you know you're going
and you just have no idea like I said I
put on the blinders and I just go
nowadays you know you sort of like take
off the blinders you but like alright
you got a you know you know I know I
don't know I'm trying to say yeah yeah
you got to have a healthy perspective
and keep it all in check you know
because we can you know I think it lose
a little bit of reality when we're you
know start spending that money that we
have even got the job yet or we're you
know what I mean just got to keep it in
check and then and even when you get the
job you just gotta like keep in check
also too then you found the love or the
love for paranormal investigation was
enhanced and maybe if it had been too
many projects all at once you wouldn't
have had time to see that I don't know
right right putting words in your mouth
well right yeah if it happened too fast
then you know in a lot you know again I
did get a lot of big things in the
beginning of my career I don't know if
it happens too fast I think I think you
could be in a lot of trouble and
everybody's everybody's timing is
different you know what I mean you could
be 10 years old and be nominated for an
act you know for a Best Best Actor and
or and that's when you're a moment
arrives or you could be 48 have your
moment arrived or you can be you know
like Bryan Cranston who has been working
for years and years and years and years
right great actor and not many people
really knew who he was and then he got
malcolm in the middle' right and
Breaking Bad
came along and now who doesn't know who
crimson is you know he's an older guy
and he had his moment you know his big
big moment with Breaking Bad so it's
like you just don't know you know and so
you just keep plugging away and you just
don't give up and just keep believing
you